welcome to this video playing our mncr I
guess maybe that's yeah I don't know
what it stands for it does not have a
flag so I cannot tell ways from so what
opening am I going to play let's let's
play this onion the statistics says I
don't turn I haven't played him before I
would have bet though that I did somehow
this handle rings a bell
let's check yeah it's a sign of a
blatant now is almost exclusively
playing 15-minute games ok the Queen
takes d4 line I don't like c96 much here
after we should be 5 so I play a 6 to
gain a temple now on the Queen is there
if I can I have 6 is there some trick
with the e5 always must be alert well I
guess I can take with the pawn yeah ok
yeah there are often districts if I take
with the night and I takes pawn takes
Bishop f7 wins the Queen oops
so I always need to be cautious um
should g5 interesting move you know I
would have maybe considered to play g6
if he had played something else but now
you don't want my pawn structure destroy
it like that so really just a six yeah
maybe okay it's a very sound way to play
this little center there's Raven again
okay
yeah well it's just a normal development
time for both sides
yeah what now I'm not sure if I should
if I should play b5e mb5 it should be
seven it looks very very normal but
there is no knight on c3 and very often
one point of b5 is that you can attack
the knight and here he might easily play
a for later but I can answer that with B
form yeah okay let's do that
and Bishop d7
no use in spending time on that so if he
goes a for I have B form okay
so yeah what's what's the plan here it's
not so easy
John maybe Quinn system to allow route
d8 landing
extra travel to d6 if necessary and yeah
okay I I guess I'll gain this this
useful move at least I believe it is a
useful move age six and and take it from
here yeah
should I play at one stage here d5 for
hmm I'm not sure okay I'll do that
maybe this this is good for a potential
d5 it covers the pawn and I also have
ideas like Knight a5 like a 5 to c4 not
100% sure that this is really doing much
good but also possible
another idea that I can consider is
night age five actually to have a
possible night F for trading on his
heaven I don't mind so much yes maybe
what he can try to do is Bishop c2
intending Bishop f6 ninety five for an
attack on h7 okay well he's doing
something else entirely
maybe oh that's that that's some points
maybe some possible sacrifice even on on
only six but ninety five looks like it
could reply possibly ninety-six later
yeah okay I want to I want to speed up a
bit I'm but behind on the clock so and
this move form cannot be too bad really
I don't think so
yeah where's the Queen going to do now
they move like twins III can be answered
by night age 5 even yeah it's actually
quite good for blood
what can he do him he can maybe go to h3
okay something else
okay well F night g6 here but Bishop d3
not so easy yeah well so I'm going I'm
going to do that I would really like to
get this bishop I'm wondering if I
should even play Queen c5 intending
Knight h5 the queen is also not not
badly placed on c5 maybe even queen h5
at some stage or not come on you know
this is one of the positions where he
can consider to to play a move like
Bishop e6 Bishop e6 every 696 getting to
pawns and the rook for two minor pieces
but his knight on d4 and the bishop on
b3 other most um most active pieces so I
don't really think that there should be
six can be so great yeah yeah I don't
expect him to to play that
I mean it's not like it's losing or or
anything but I don't really believe it
it is particularly great
okay so if it would be my move just to
consider the plan I would probably play
Knight h5 and gain the bishop on g3 this
is something that he might address with
the move like yeah well if he plays h3
I'm still going to do Knight h5
intending also not as well oops
the Baba you need to answer that
sot/video back on I needed to to to
answer the doorbell got new chess books
delivered delivered
okay so Knight h5 yeah I guess so you
feel the text the Queen with before or
any other moves I will take g3 with an
intermediate attack on the Queen so I
really get the bishop which is good news
if you have two bishop air it always
feels like you you only need to exchange
the other stuff and win the game but
it's not that easy usually
yeah my I've gotten two new chess books
delivered we'll check them out after
finishing the video there's a new
grandmaster repertoire book by Israeli
Grandmaster Borissov look on the the
sloth defense always one of the the main
openings against deform and well rock is
always doing an excellent job of
covering openings he's the author author
of many many good books the g4
repertoire the Grune felt dealing with
his books about default deviations great
stuff okay so he played Queen f3 so I
wonder how to how to continue the Queen
on f6 sound maybe I'm sorry on g5 maybe
95 coming Nagi form also rook c8 is a
good move coming next
yeah the the problem that white has in
this position is besides the fact that
black has the two bishops it's not
really obvious what White's plan is he
does not really have an attacking plan
on the kingside or any any direct way to
continue and that makes it difficult in
f4 f5 is not a good plan the bone
structure on the Kings side as a whole
has gotten a bit of a bit of inflexible
with the double pawn him and well the
Queen side this is also not not an area
we have vacant can do much but some it's
really tricky yeah I made five my
intention is to play a possible
Najee form - just made a threaten made
and go from there yeah okay I can go to
G form and now he's he always must be
cautious that he's got the knight on f3
to defend the mate
that's not comfortable to play really
and there there are tactics coming up
I'm pretty sure about that a combination
that I am okay but what exactly is the
point if ifs not not really on e5 I mean
from from the white side
piano playing e5 myself is not doing me
any good done just g6 yeah maybe even
come on just g6 so that after a five I
can just take it take it and win and it
might offer or might introduce the later
possibility to play e5 myself oh here
then I can just take really I don't see
why not
and Queen takes with a double attack
age - and f2
you're hard to cover both both things
yeah maybe Queen have three mm-hmm
it's not really a happy move but I don't
see a watch why should do
yeah I guess you must play Queen a3 I
don't I don't see what else if he em
yeah okay maybe maybe rook the two but
it's not really it's not really great
you know
yeah I'm just going from that father for
the simple method take here King edge
one and the question is if I have
something better than Queen takes you
one which will just net the exchange
Queenie one night f2 you know maybe you
can argue that he is very close to being
checkmated him like rook c8 rook c5 rook
h5 and and it's gone but does I keep it
simple this is just winning the exchange
and getting the Queen's off so I have
already want to pawn some an exchange in
two pawns as plenty check
came so um not not very difficult from a
technical point of view I just need to
open up the position for the rooks so d5
at a any good moment if I go d5 now he
might play e5 which it's not opening up
the position so quickly
but I have many strengths and he moves
first I can for example play something
like King g7 like okay like this is the
the easiest plan I can incoming
challenge like I can do something like
King g7 f 6 e 5 and then G 5 protecting
a 5 so then D 5 will be easily played
without losing a upon it so that's the
easy easy way to play in general this
position is some it's not so easy for
Wyatt because he lacks an apparent plan
how to continue his pieces are not so
aggressively placed so it's it's not
easy to say what what you should do
after that I feel like like it's already
better because I mean it's the two
bishops and he does not have any
particular compensation for it I mean I
don't I don't see what what he has I
mean maybe I'm computer wants to go
before even Jam it's maybe better you
know he cannot take d4 hangs okay but I
just I just I just claim a claim here
that in the long run like it's better
anyway because of the the bishop am and
and here he's already a bit tied down
how does he ever move his pieces with
the the thread own age to hang above his
head this I played g6 it's not strictly
necessary
believe but yeah in fact it isn't maybe
I should have just played a move like
that if he goes in e5 then this is
actually a complete disaster
because it has opened up everything here
something like that is fantastic for
black
I'm almost threatening rook takes tea
for him yeah that's that's even winning
I guess like immediately okay but g6
wasn't a problem yeah this is this
thing's but it's not very comfortable
for white anyway I have very very easy
easy plans coming like rook c8 possibly
'if I've and d5 opening it up and
there's always this threat looming so
it's it's very tricky for for white to
play he probably should actually get the
bishop back here it's not doing much but
not very comfortable to play all right
thanks for watching